let's get some analysis on them all by
bringing in the former RAF Air Marshal
Ed streamer who's joining us now Ed good
to speak with you again just tell us the
Russians have now hit residential
buildings in zapparitzia why is that a
Target
well the Russian army is losing
tactically on the battlefield as you see
on the map to my right here the uh in
yellow up around harciv and then most
recently down at the bottom left there
her son where the Russian army really
hit quite rapidly has collapsed so Putin
is going to have to try to regain the
initiative strategically and there are
many audiences he needs he needs to
consider consider many constituencies uh
and he needs everybody to be scared of
him and scared that Russia can still
escalate so you have seen most recently
the announcement of calling up 300 000
reservists to join it to join the Army
and of course the way of keeping
everyone scared is to continue these
strikes but into as you say residential
areas in in zapparitzia itself which is
the major regional center of the
zaparitzia oblast though to reassure uh
the viewers that's still 50 miles away
from zapparitzia the nuclear uh Power
Plant that's sort of important area as
part of this one you mentioned the
constituents is that Putin has to kind
of keep happy as he continues
Prosecuting as well just take us through
some of the people and areas that he
needs to try and maintain
yeah well the war hasn't gone his way
it's not all over in four days and
suddenly it's got very it's got very
difficult for him
um at home he has got to keep those
radical Russian nationalists happy
because they're the most vocal
supporters of his War here on the
picture there bottom left ramzan kadarov
the Chechen the man who has been most
recklessly calling for the use of
Battlefield nuclear weapons to try and
regain that initiative and so Putin has
an interest in reminding everybody has
got the power to use these nuclear
weapons not least Us in the west
represented there by President United
States Joe Biden but he also has to
convince the West you can deal with him
he's you know he's a rational actor and
if you look at the third constituency
represented here by Xi Jinping those
superpowers who have been tacit
supporters or like India neutral and
they don't want
um uh to see the Russians use nuclear
weapons so he's got to reassure them
that he's still very much sane and on
side these are difficult messages so
behind the nuclear saber rattling that's
got us all scared what you've actually
seen is both the state information
department on Monday and then just today
the Foreign Affairs Ministry come out
and remind everybody that Russian
nuclear policy hasn't changed it will
only be used if the very Heartland of
the Russian Federation is threatened and
they're reminding everybody that in
their view no one benefits if you go to
nuclear war so it remains a very serious
thing but still I would judge unlikely
okay and for now thanks for that